Gunther est peut-être le tueur à gages le plus redouté qui
travaille dans l'industrie aujourd'hui tu
veux être roi tu dois tuer le roi
tout le monde sait qui il est
Gunther Gunther c'est le plus grand homme de
tous les temps dans le mille je serai le gars tué j'ai
monté une équipe imparable
je suis  Donald son méchant va boum boum
j'essaie de démarrer ça boum va la
dynamite
mon nom est Sonam produit '
mon premier meurtre professionnel était à l'
âge de 8 ans est que des choses fraîches il
y a notre arme secrète dont j'ai besoin pour trouver
une fenêtre et  quand j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait un groupe d'assassins qui essayaient de me tuer,
je me suis énervé, j'ai
été un peu difficile au début, je veux le
tuer encore plus maintenant, je me
précipite au-dessus de nos têtes
FBI, je voudrais signaler que
vous êtes bien  je vais essayer de le tuer à nouveau